all right sir
on april the 14th 1865
65 years ago
lincoln was present at a performance at
ford's theater
there was a large audience present i had
a seat in the orchestra
nearly beneath the box of the president
the first two acts passed off presently
and the curtain roads for the threat and
left act
few if any words were spoken on the
stage
and they've heard the shark report over
the barber
i look towards the place when the sound
came
and saw a boot climbing over the rail in
front of the box
and jumped to the stage a few feet to
his right
when he struck the stage he kind of
staggered
raising his right hand holding a knife
he said
six separate tyrannos and ran to the
rear of the stage
and escaped through an area
the audience around me now were
outstanding
they appeared to be shot got
much talk going on the people began to
move out of the siever
and when i reached the exit there were a
large crowd in the street
there was shouting hanging venturing the
guardian
i took refuge on the porch of it
and shortly thereafter the men killing
the president entered the house
where i stood i stepped off the porch
that they may enter the president died
the following morning
in that hour
[Music]
haha
uh
you